my tribe was on the verge of its
greatest Victory the last of the owl
Warriors had been located soon long
claude's Emerald Secrets would be ours
but my father stopped me from joining
the fight he said my moment to honor our
tribe would come but it was not this
moment those were the last words he
spoke to me
I never saw him again
both lost everything that day
goodbye Sonic
[Music]
are you okay deceiver
no no it wasn't a trip
Tails take the compass and get out of
here
[Music]
good
tails come on wake up he chose helping
the fox over pursuing the compass yeah
of course he did new friends same
pathetic weakness
oh no no no no no okay we're in real
trouble here come on Tails I need you to
fly us out of here time to wake up
[Music]
see you kids enjoy the fresh powder
okay you can do this
I gotta go fast
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
hahaha
I don't want to die like this it's
derivative
we got it
great
still by petals more or less
fire in the hole
I've solved it
there's a booby trap every seven seconds
that was a little early
so glad it didn't cut off my
mustache hey little red Wrecking Ball
I know you're dying to get your Emerald
on but can we be a little bit more
mindful of our surroundings
may I
do 30 feet turn left work smarter not
harder
and if you want that Emerald you're
gonna have to go through me
foreign
[Music]
hmm too easy
let's do this
[Music]
why don't you stand still and Die With
Honor let me think about it okay I
thought about it
hi there beautiful
you're the real deal aren't you
say goodbye Hedgehog
knuckle stop robotnik's stealing the
emerald what kind of fool do you take
before just look my
wait that wasn't the
date oh
you poor naive creature it's not your
fault a more advanced intellect would
have seen this move coming a mile away
or 1.6 kilometers but I trusted you
you are my friend
[Laughter]
I'm sorry
that just hit me funny
let this be my final lesson to you you
dim-witted Celestial skin tag
friends
are open honest and vulnerable with each
other which means x squared times the
hypotenuse of Y squared divided by the
absolute value of friendship equals
dookie
oh no
chaos
is
[Music]